we're going for a ride by ruling
defending position not this Oh later I
enter and I see you she will she will
likely just want to lay down here watch
and it's her job to not do that you see
how she had to catch up so you might
fall lower you might but now you got to
get up and follow okay any UK here lays
down lay down
guess what that's your correction you
get too many of those that you become by
you kick okay you don't want that go to
drop him there you see but I enter over
here
she wants to lay down no that's one
correction so it just gets worse from
here so what you want to do is move with
me that's better now wait who gets not
dead at the bottom you understand that's
how you can you where you just die right
here
you're constantly filling in and gone so
when she feels that yes there you go
then I develop a skill
yes very good okay go